okay hi everyone
welcome to another episode of science
and technology q a for
kids and others let's see
we have a whole bunch of stored up
questions here
um
um
well let me see i've got one
this is a very unkid there are a bunch
of very unkid questions here
uh the question about supersymmetry okay
um i can try to explain a little bit
about supersymmetry
it's a it's a slightly complicated
concept
okay let's talk first about symmetry
what is ordinary symmetry of things
so for example if i have
something like a square i could say just
have a square
it's unlabeled you just drawn a square i
could say the square has certain
symmetries
you could flip it you could rotate it by
90 degrees
you'll get back something that's just
like the square you had to begin with
you can flip it around an axis you'll
get back something just like the square
you had to begin with
and so you can have this notion
of symmetries ways to make
transformations on something
so that the thing ends up being back
just the way it was when you
started so for example if you have a
circle
it has a continuous symmetry in the
sense that you can rotate it through any
angle and it's just a
it's a pure circle pure abstract circle
it's not actually
you know made from uh you know a piece
of plastic or something it's it's just
an abstract circle
whatever angle you rotate it through
it's still just going to be that same
abstract circle again
so it has sort of a continuous symmetry
a square would have a discrete symmetry
then rotate it through 90 degrees you
can flip it you can reflect it
and do other things that leave it
unchanged
and so things have for example different
degrees of symmetry for example
a square has certain symmetries that has
the rotation symmetries it has
reflection symmetries
the circle has this continuous rotation
symmetry
if i make a a weird shape thing you know
a picture
of uh well like a like a human roughly
you know you have a picture of a person
it roughly has bilateral symmetry it's
roughly symmetric if you were to
reflect have a mirror reflection roughly
it's not actually
true in in detail for people but in at
least a rough approximation
we're all kind of about the same size we
look about the same on on the left is on
the right although not exactly
um but uh at least an idealized person
might be
identical left left right identical so
that's sort of a bilateral symmetry
so these are all uh different kinds of
of symmetry operations the the the
reflection the rotation
these are all different kinds of
symmetry operations that you can
apply to kind of concrete kinds of uh
well actually i should say kind of
mathematical kinds of constructs
like idealized squares idealized
triangles and so on
okay so supersymmetry
is a very elaborate generalization
of these ideas um
let me see what is the best way to get
into explaining it
um well let me see
okay when it comes to
this kind of you have a square you can
uh you can kind of flip it upside down
you'll still get the same square
you can ask the same kinds of things for
particles like an electron for example
if you take an electron what is the
symmetry of an electron what
what can you do with an electron and
have it
still seem like it's it's the same thing
so for example you might say uh you
could
uh let's say you you've got this
electron you flip it
i mean you might um uh this is this is
very tricky because the actual
mathematical formalism
that describes electrons is fairly
different
from what we need to just be talking
about
kind of material objects and turning
them upside down and things like this
um let me let me okay so
electrons have this
attribute called spin which is roughly
we can think of it as
the thing is spinning around and has
some axis that it's spinning around
in reality an electron at least in
traditional physics
is a point particle that has zero size
so it's kind of hard to understand how
it has an angular momentum
from spinning around in our theory of
physics it doesn't have zero size
it's a little easier to understand how
that works but anyway the end result is
it has the same momentum and an electron
has the feature
that has a certain symmetry that allows
the angular momentum
uh roughly it could either be spinning
up or spinning down
and it can't be at some angle in between
that it couldn't be it's not something
where you can continuously change the
angle
in some sense and i'm cheating a little
bit because this
to really say that depends on a bunch of
the formalism of quantum mechanics
and how quantum measurement works and a
bunch of other things
um but in in a first approximation you
can think of it it's either
with respect to some way of observing it
it's either spinning in an up direction
or it's spinning in a down direction
it's either got its axis pointed up it's
either spinning clockwise or
counterclockwise
um and so you can think of the electron
as having
this kind of um this kind of symmetry
that's associated you can just flip it
from
pointing up to pointing down and um
when we look at different kinds of
particles we can
uh yeah this gets really complicated
um all right let me let me talk about it
in a slightly different way
so
there are electrons which have charge
minus one
there's also the anti-particle of an
electron which has charge plus one
when you look at other kinds of
particles like quarks
quarks have something that's like
electric charge it's not electrochild
it's called color charge
and a quark there are uh
kind of three uh
unlike electric charge which is just a
scalar number
it's you know it could be plus some
number minus some number
um electric charge happens to be
quantized so it has to be you have to
have
some multiple of actually one third of
the charge of the electron
but you have to have a definite multiple
of some fixed quantity
as an electric charge color charge you
can have a fixed a multiple of a fixed
quantity
but that uh the the
the reason it's called color charge is
because it kind of has three direct
three three independent components
associated with it you can think of as
kind of the
red green and blue components of color
charge
well okay so we're getting closer to
being able to talk about silver symmetry
here
um we can think about symmetries as in
a red quark it isn't really red it's
just a mathematical
thing that behaves a bit like color um
a red quark you can kind of rotate that
in some internal sense of rotation not
physical rotation but it's a rotation in
color space
rather than in physical space and color
only in quotes as well because it's not
actual color like the things we see
it's just a mathematical quantity that
behaves a little bit like color
you can sort of rotate it in color space
and you end up you you start with a red
quark and then
turn it into a green quark it's like
saying but but you still
you you've not changed uh you you
you kind of can uh you you've not
fundamentally changed the object that
you have
you can um okay
boy this is surprisingly difficult to
explain
okay it um uh
wow all right um
the next concept we need uh
okay so i think i've maybe talked about
this on previous occasions
when you look at particles like
electrons and photons
things like that electrons sort of the
units of electric charge
photons the the things that are
components of light and
and uh and other electromagnetic
radiation
these are these are what are often
called elementary particles
we don't know how to break an electron
into anything smaller
at least not until our current theory of
physics where we do understand some
things like that
but electrons and photons have always
seemed like they're elementary particles
okay electrons and photons have uh
there are two different kinds of
particles an electron is an example of a
thing called the fermion
uh a photon is an example of a thing
called the boson
and there are lots of kinds of things
that are fermions protons are fermions
neutrons are fermions
uh muons are fermions um all
all kinds of particles quarks are
fermions
on the on the boson side photons of
bosons
and uh gravitons the particles of
gravity are bosons
um the higgs boson is a boson as its
name might suggest
there are a bunch of particles that are
bosons what are the differences between
these kinds of particles
well the most important difference is
one that comes from quantum mechanics
and essentially fermions have the
property that
no two fermions want to be in the same
place at the same time
and if you take two electrons you try
and put them both
in the same kind of quantum state same
place same time same
same spin same everything they won't let
you do it
there's a thing called the pali
exclusion principle that prevents
electrons from always being in the same
place and being in the same place at the
same time
that attribute of not wanting to
electrons not
wanting to be sort of crushed together
in the same place in the same time is
pretty important for us because
it's basically what leads to the
stability of matter it's what causes
mata just not to sort of just collapse
bosons on the other hand have the
opposite point of view
bosons like to be in the same state at
the same time
and that's why lasers for example work
they collect lots of photons in the same
state
at the same time and that's why you have
this coherent beam of laser light
that can be produced by a laser so
fermions
have this don't want to get together
bosons always want to get together
okay important fact from particle
physics is that
you can tell whether something is going
to be a fermion or a boson
by looking at its spin so things with
half and
just spins like spin a half for example
uh
fermions things with integer spin like
spin zero like higgs boson spin one like
the photon
those are always bosons okay
so super symmetry supersymmetry
is a kind of symmetry in which you turn
bosons into fermions and vice versa
so just as we talked about you know you
can just physically rotate something in
space
you can kind of rotate in color space
from a red quark to a green cork
and these things sort of leave you it
it leaves you the same uh in in some
abstract sense when you do that rotation
so the rotation of the of the abstract
square the rotation
of the red quark to green cork and so on
okay there's another much more bizarre
form of rotation
which is a rotation from bosons to
fermions
and vice versa okay well there's a small
problem with this idea
and the problem is that that in order
for it to be the case that you could
just do a rotation and so
nothing would change it would have to be
true that there will be these
pairs of particles that are sort of
bosons and fermions that are really just
like the same kind of thing
like you could have a quark that is a
fermion
and some kind of squirk that is a
supersymmetric partner of the quark
that is a boson you'd have to have a
fermion a boson that really
were pretty much the same except that
one for example had spina half and one
had spin zero
and one was a fermion one was a boson so
super symmetry is the idea it's kind of
a mathematical idea
of being able to take particles that are
bosons
and sort of just by uh and always find
that there are sort of partners of those
particles you can get to by making this
uh super symmetric transformation so to
speak um
that will be will be you know if it
started from the fermion will be a boson
and vice versa
okay so this is this is the idea it is
a mathematically quite elegant idea
why do people care about this idea okay
there's a very
this is a little bit complicated but i
think i can explain it
the in in particle physics
uh okay the the big picture is a bunch
of theories work out a lot nicer if
they're
super symmetric than if they're not and
i can kind of explain why
although it's a little bit tricky and it
has to do with this
exclusion principle fermions like to
stay away from each other bosons like to
collect together
it has to do with the way that that
exclusion principle plays itself out
in detailed calculations in particle
physics
okay deep breath here we're going to
dive into something
slightly different and um okay
uh when
this what i'm going to talk about is is
uh
so-called virtual particles okay
you have an electron it's just it's you
it's just sort of hanging out
well and uh
the any electron
as a result of quantum mechanics has
a certain it has a certain probability
to be an electron together with a photon
in other words it has a the electron
it's it's like you think you have an
electron
but actually there's some uncertainty
about whether it really is just an
electron
or whether it's an electron plus a
photon and
what can happen is the electrons going
along it uh
emits a photon and it loses some of
its energy it gives some of its energy
to a photon and
the photon goes off and then slightly
even more bizarrely
a very very short time later the photon
is reabsorbed by the electron
so the end result is nothing really
happened the electron was just tooling
along very happily
and it emitted a photon and then
reabsorbed the photon
it's like what what difference does that
make
well the uh in
what's also true about quantum mechanics
is that
the way that this question of whether
it's sort of allowed to do that
depends on kind of whether it has kind
of the energy budget to be able to do it
does it can it give up some of its
energy to the photon and
absorb it and does that really work with
energy momentum and so on
it turns out that um
boy this is complicated to explain
the what happens is
that if you are if it's for a
sufficiently short time
the usual rules for what for example the
mass of the electron should be
can be or the effective mass worked out
in terms of energy momentum should be
can be violated but only for a short
time and the amount of violation
the shorter the time the larger the
violation this is part of the
uncertainty principle
a heisenberg uncertainty principle which
in its sort of official version
says things like delta e times delta t
is uh um uh is
is less than or equal to h bar
um so the uh delta e means the
uncertainty in energy delta t
is sort of the uncertainty in time and
this is um uh uh this
is something well the um
uh that there's there's a it's not zero
so the
that you can have you can either trade
off you can have more uncertainty in
energy
for less for a shorter time less
uncertainty in time or vice versa
and so the end result of this is that
any particle
that's just tooling along can have sort
of a cloud of virtual particles
that for very short amounts of time sort
of appear
outside of that particle then get
reabsorbed and so that's what happens
with electrons
it's the what happens with corks
is more extreme quarks are continually
emitting and reabsorbing gluons
um because the the interaction rate
between quarks and gluons
is higher than between photons and
electrons it's a more dramatic effect
but either way when you do the
mathematics of this
it turns out that the effect is actually
and this is again rather a complicated
thing
the effect is actually infinite the
effect of electrons
emitting and reabsorbing photons that
produces
essentially a shift in the effective
mass of the electron
and and yes this is very bizarre that
shift is actually infinite
when you just work it out mathematically
actually in our theory of physics it
wouldn't be precisely infinite but the
same
kinds of uh thinking will still apply
and um the reason it's infinite
is that there will be a contribution
from
uh photons electrons that are sort of
arbitrarily far away from where they
should be
but for an arbitrarily short time and
when you include all of those
contributions you add them all up
you end up realizing that it's an
infinite contribution
to the so-called self-mass of the
electron okay so
uh sometime in the 1940s my late friend
dick finem
was one people pointed out that okay
it's all very nice
that the self-mass of the electron as a
result of this
this self-interaction of uh of you know
emitting and reabsorbing photons
will have an infinite effect on the mass
but so what
because uh for every electron we see
it's already it has that effect has
already happened
so maybe what that's really true is that
the
effective mass the true bare mass of the
electron
is minus infinity and then added to that
is the infinity that comes from the self
and the result is the actual mass of the
electron
so the question is how would you know
that that theory that theory seems like
a complete put up job
but it's uh but how would you know that
theory was
was not true well the only way you'd
know that wasn't true is if you could do
something to an electron
to have that balance be broken between
the the negative the infinite negative
bare mass
and the infinite positive self-mass and
actually there are
by sort of perturbing the electron by
kicking the electron
you can kind of see the way that those
that that balance is no longer precisely
correct it comes about
through this thing called the
renalization group um but the basic idea
of you can subtract infinity and add
infinity
and just get the number that you observe
is the way that is this
sort of trick called realization okay
well all of this stuff about virtual
particles being produced
and then being being absorbed again
happens all over the place it's it's
sort of the generic thing that happens
in quite a field theory
so for example if you have a photon just
tooling along and uh
it will uh every so often it will split
into an electron positron pair
which will then exist for a short time
and then will be it will kind of
annihilate again turning into a photon
so every photon
is sort of every so often it's kind of
turning into this virtual particle pair
and disappearing again
okay well again there's an infinite
effect from all of those virtual
particle pairs
being produced and being being
annihilating again
okay there's an infinite effect but the
size of the effect
when the pair of particles that are
produced are bosons
is has a plus sign associated with it
when the pair of particles that are
produced are fermions it has a minus
sign associated with it
that plus sign and minus sign directly
come from this whole
exclusion principle versus wanting to
get together thing although the details
a little bit complicated about how that
works
but in any case the main result is that
this effect
of what's called vacuum polarization
this phenomenon of a photon can
can turn into a pair of particles and
then uh turn back into a photon again
that has contributions from boson loops
pairs of bosons and fermion loops pairs
of pairs of fermions or
boson antibodies on forming an
anti-feminine pairs
okay the big trick is plus sign for
bosons minus sign for fermions
okay why is this relevant well if
supersymmetry was there
it would turn out to be the case that
the boson numbers that there will be
exactly for every boson there will be a
super partner of the boson that's a
fermion and vice versa
so that means that that plus sign that
would be contributed by these bosons in
this loop
would be cancelled by their their
partner fermions in the loop
so the result would be that instead of
getting this infinite effect
you would actually get a zero effect you
would have a precise cancellation
between the bosons
and the fermions in this loop and that's
the trick
that is used in in supersymmetry and
supergravity
in super string theory et cetera et
cetera et cetera that's
that's the key trick that's used is if
you could only have these pairs of
bosons and phones together
you would get this cancellation and you
wouldn't have to deal with these kinds
of infinities
okay so is that actually true in the
real world well no
not for the actual particles we observe
but it is the case
that there are ways to spontaneously
break that symmetry
again this gets us into a whole nother
complicated can of worms
that ends with the higgs boson or at
least one branch of it ends with a higgs
boson
um that that is the thing where you can
sort of have the symmetry
but the symmetry is not manifest
because of something about the world not
about the system itself
so in the case of the higgs mechanism
what's happening there
is that there's lots of interesting
symmetries that come about
if all particles have zero mass but
clearly particles don't all have zero
mass otherwise
we wouldn't see that what we see um and
the question is how do they get mass
and so one theory for how they get mass
is to say they really don't have any
mass intrinsically
but there's this medium that exists
throughout the universe
and as particles move through this
medium they're continually interacting
with that medium
and the result of those interactions is
the particle's behaviors if they have
mass
and that's the theory of this thing
called the higgs mechanism that
it says that this higgs there's a
there's a higgs field
that fills the universe actually a very
sort of high density there's this higgs
field
that fills the universe but you can't
and it has the effect that whenever
particles
move in the universe they're continually
interacting with this higgs field
and that's what gives the mass how can
we tell the higgs field is there
well actually you can make little you
can sort of kick the higgs field and it
has little perturbations
in the higgs field itself and those are
the higgs bosons that's the higgs
particle
but was discovered and actually the
higgs particle confusingly enough
itself gets mass from interaction with
the higgs field and it happens to have a
mass
of 125 times the mass of the proton
roughly and it was discovered a few
years ago
in particle in particle accelerator
experiments
um but any case that so this idea of
spontaneous symmetry making
the theory really has a symmetry like a
symmetry that makes particles have zero
mass
or the symmetry that's like bosons and
fermions all come in pairs
but there's spontaneous symmetry
breaking because
not because the theory itself breaks the
symmetry but because there's something
sort of
outside the theory there's a state of
the world that breaks the symmetry
that is sort of independent of the
innards of the theory so to speak
and so people try to make that work for
supersymmetry um
i'm not sure how successful this really
all is because
uh the the sort of key thing would be if
we actually observe these super pairs
of um of particles and their super
partners which we haven't yet
now you might ask in our whole theory of
physics how does this work
and um let's see is that explainable
it might be okay so in our theory of
physics
we start off from this idea that space
is not a continuous thing
space is made from discrete points and
there's this kind of graph that that
represents how these various points
are related to each other okay one
the way that everything the universe
happens the way that time progresses
is that little pieces of this uh graph
of all these connections between these
atoms of space
there there are lots of uh of updates
that happen on this graph and they
happen all over the graph and they're
happening all the time and
everything we're doing and everything
that's happening in the world
is associated with just you know
trillions and trillions and trillions of
trillions of updates happening every
second
in this in this giant network that
represents space and represents the
universe
okay but things get more complicated
than that because
it turns out there isn't just one way
these updates
can happen at any moment there are
actually many ways these updates can
happen at any moment
and this is how quantum mechanics shows
up in in
sort of classical physics before about
120 years ago
people always thought in physics
there's a definite thing that happens
you know
you uh throw a dart
the dart goes in a definite direction it
depends determined by
the particular momentum it started with
and all those other parameters
that's classical physics in quantum
physics
there's the idea well actually the dart
goes in all possible directions all
possible places
and there's a certain chance that it
goes in each different direction
and when we when we see where the dart
went
we will be able with a certain
probability it will go in one direction
versus another direction
and so so that's the idea of quantum
mechanics quantum physics the key idea
is
sort of everything happens but all
things that things happen with different
probabilities whereas in classical
physics it's just
a definite thing happens so
in our theory the way that works is in
all these little updates that happen on
this
whole graph that represents the universe
there are many different ways the
updates can happen and each possible way
the updates can happen
represents a different possible history
for the universe a history for the
universe where the dart went one
direction versus another direction and
so on
and then this is where things get a
little bit more complicated
the that you can actually represent the
states of the universe
in terms of another graph so where the
universe is in some particular state
there are let's say a billion different
things that could happen
from that state of the universe to get
to a new state of the universe
so we can represent that by having a
point in the graph
and then in this network and then it has
connections to a billion
other uh uh nodes in this network
that represent the new possible states
of the universe and then those will have
connections to other states the universe
and so on
okay so a big factor is that
just as you can branch out one state of
the universe
can end up having two different possible
updates that lead to two different
states of the universe
it can also be the case that two
different states of the universe
can converge because there
there are updates that can happen on
those that will end them up being
identical
so you have this notion of this sort of
branching and merging
and this thing we call the multi-way
graph that represents this kind of
map of possible histories of the
universe
okay so what does this have to do with
any of these other
things so it turns out uh
our suspicion is that
and and there are many pieces of this a
little hard to explain but our suspicion
is
that uh bosons are roughly associated
with
things where in the multi-way graph
merging happens very quickly
and fermions are associated with things
in the multi-way graph
where merging takes a long time to
happen roughly
so why does that make any sense the the
merging happens quickly
idea is kind of like all these different
well it's a little hard to hard to go
through all of this but
but it's it's roughly the idea it's that
all these different possible things that
might be happening with a photon
they all can be combined together
whereas all the different things that
could happen with an electron they're
all split apart
and we think that's what leads to the
exclusion principle for fermions
the uh uh the sort of get-together idea
for bosons which which leads to
phenomena like
phenomenon of bose-einstein condensation
that that um
has been observed not only for photons
but also now for atoms and things
um but any case so that's that's uh so
uh if you ask me uh how does
supersymmetry work
in our models is there an analog of
supersymmetry
there is it's a kind of transformation
on our multi-way graphs
and it's kind of complicated and to what
extent it is a precise symmetry of our
models we don't know
it doesn't seem to be a precise symmetry
of of the universe but
it's something that at a sort of
abstract mathematical level we can
investigate
um
let's see um
uh
okay a few questions here which i might
be able to answer and then maybe i'll
try and do
um one other slightly complicated one
there's one from m9 here do the
particles
mass vary or are they the same all the
time that's a really good question
so for an electron is the mass of an
electron always
0.511 mev which is the units of electron
mass
um is it always that okay tricky
question
so first of all there are two meanings
to mass one is
so-called inertial mass and the other is
so-called gravitational mass
and the uh the inertial mass
is kind of how much when if you if you
wanted to
get the electron moving at a certain
speed how much force do you have to
exert
to get it to do that the gravitational
mass
is how much gravity will be produced by
the
by the existence by the presence of that
um uh
of that electron and there's this thing
called the principle of equivalence
which says that the inertial mass is
equal to the gravitational mass
but there's sort of a different story
oh boy boy these questions get difficult
very quickly
um according to current physics
um well let me see how to say this
correctly
uh according to current physics
when you do particle physics you always
assume that the inertial mass of an
electron
is a fixed number now um
the there's a bit more wiggle room for
the gravitational mass of the electron
and for thinking about that but maybe i
shouldn't go down that path and let me
explain a slightly different way in
which
mass can vary um the
um in
let me see by the way in our theory
the equivalence of gravitational and
inertial mass
uh i actually have not thought this yeah
okay yes
okay so first point is is it actually
true that particles have the same
inertia mass as gravitational mass
it's true to about one part and ten to
the fifteen so one part and a thousand
trillion
um that's actually the best measurement
i think is still
the measurement of the precise distance
to the moon
and the calculation of how the distance
to the moon varies with time
the precise distance the moon is found
by the the best measurements i think is
still found from the lunar laser retro
reflector
that was left there by the apollo
astronauts
you shine a laser beam at the moon it
bounces off this retro reflector that
works kind of like the
the way that road signs work they have
little glass granules in them that
reflect the light back to where it came
from so if you've got your headlights
and you're
they're shining at them uh at the at the
um at the road sign
you'll tend to get most of the light
back in your direction rather than just
shining off in random directions
so the lunar laser retro reflector works
kind of the same way
and you shine laser beam at the moon and
you get a decent
amount of laser light coming back and by
precisely measuring the time
it takes for the laser light to get to
the moon and back again
you can work out very accurately to
within i think millimeters nowadays
the distance to the moon or at least to
that part of the moon and from that it's
been possible to work out this
gravitational mass
versus inertial mass question
so a couple of different questions is
the gravitational mass always the same
in the different
times in the history of the universe um
is the inertial mass always the same how
does that
work okay the the
the inertial mass which is kind of the
mass that you talk about in quantum
mechanics
um is in in the current theory of
physics
that mass comes from the higgs mechanism
that mass comes because they're really
the electron
should have had zero mass but because
there's this higgs field that exists
throughout the universe
it's we can't tell it exists except for
these little perturbations that
that happen on it the higgs particles at
this
this higgs field that exists throughout
the universe the electrons are going
through that higgs field
and effectively getting mass by their
interactions with the higgs field
it's kind of more or less the same way
that when you have
uh light going photons going through the
vacuum they go at the speed of light
and and so on but if you have uh light
going through water for example it goes
um uh at um uh
uh about one about three quarters the
speed
that it goes in um uh
um in the vacuum and the reason it goes
through towards the speed and not
not faster is because those photons are
continually being
absorbed and re-emitted by atoms in the
water
and that absorption re-emission slows
down
that sort of takes some time for the
absorption re-emission to happen
that's not exactly how it works with the
higgs field but it's very close to how
it works for the higgs field
um there's uh okay and by the way the
the
the utter cheat is which looks really
bad when you first hear about it is
you say why does an electron have one
mass the muon have another mass
the uh the the quarks have different
masses and so on
well the answer is that they couple with
different strengths of the higgs field
and so in other words their mass is just
a reflection
of their coupling to the higgs field you
say well but but
you know that's just to cheat you're
putting in the answer for what the mass
is by saying how strongly they couple
to the higgs field and the answer is yes
you're doing that we don't independently
know how to compute masses of particles
yet
perhaps our theory will give us a way to
do that it's looking actually rather
promising but it will
but we don't currently know how to do
that okay
so particles get their mass from this
continual interaction of the higgs field
okay question is has the higgs field
always been there
or did the higgs field at some point not
exist in the universe
well it turns out the the little bit of
a hack
that says why this higgs field now
has to do with the you assume
the higgs field has interactions with
itself
and this sounds so hacky when i describe
it
the higgs field has an effective
negative mass
and effective self-interactions and the
combination of those two things
leads it to have what's called a vacuum
expectation value
it leads it to have a certain fixed
value throughout the universe
and mathematically what happens is
there's essentially an equation
that says what the what's called the
effective potential
it's effectively what the it's roughly
what the
effective energy of the universe would
be and when you minimize that
you have this kind of you have this kind
of picture
that you get where it has a minimum uh
that is away from field equals zero
so higgs field equals for most for most
particles
they don't have a strong
self-interaction and this weird negative
mass thing
and they they're the expected value the
vacuum expectation value
of the intensity of the particle is zero
in a vacuum there isn't any of that
particle
but for the higgs field because of this
weird self-interaction property
the vacuum expectation value is not zero
and that's what leads in this rather
hacky
setup to uh this to the presence of this
higgs condensate this higgs
value of the higgs field throughout the
universe okay that's all well and good
but it turns out the universe hasn't
always been the way it is today
the universe used to be a lot hotter
than it is today
and it turns out when you think about
this thing that's sort of minimizing the
energy
by being in this local minimum of the
affected potential
that's away from zero value of the field
that it's kind of like the thing is
rolling down it's going into this
this minimum but when you have it
when you have it be hotter heat is
effectively jiggling things around it
jiggles things around jiggles things
around a lot
eventually when it gets hot enough it's
no longer stuck in that minimum
and actually it can jiggle all the way
and the effective vacuum expectation
value is zero
it's a bit similar to what happens in a
magnet for example in a ferromagnet
what's happening is that in a magnet the
magnetism is the result
of lots of little electron spins all
lined up
lots of little um well basically we we
can say um
there are lots of things that there are
lots of little tiny bar magnets that are
made from atoms
and the question is do all the tiny bar
magnets line up so
you take two bar magnets and put them
next to each other they will
they will tend to line up that's just
the way magnetism works
but if you if you and so in this
when you've lined them all up in in the
magnet they all
line up together they make a big
magnetic field from all these little
tiny bar magnets made of atoms lining up
but if you heat up the um uh
if you heat up the bar a piece of iron
then
these atoms will start being kicked
around all over the place and they'll no
longer be lining up
and there's a particular critical
temperature it's called the curie
temperature
i think it's named after pierre curie
marie curie's husband
um the uh uh it
um uh at the curie temperature
which i think is 56 degrees centigrade
maybe for iron
i may be wrong um but in any case at the
curie temperature at a definite
temperature
there's so much jiggling around of the
of the of the atoms
that this lining up that makes
a uh you know makes the the
the magnet have a big magnetic field is
broken
and instead it will have on average zero
magnetic field
so if you take a bar magnet and you just
heat it up a lot if you take your
average magnet and just heat it up a lot
it will lose its magnetism
so if you wanted your your thing to be
magnetic don't do that i mean you can
give it back magnetism again by cooling
it down
and putting it in a magnetic field so it
will line up all those all those
atomic uh magnets again but um uh you
destroy the magnetism by putting it in a
in a higher temperature so
the same thing happens essentially with
the higgs field when uh
when it's at low temperature sort of
things are all
not quite aligned but things are all set
up so this higgs field
has a net non-zero value of higgs field
just like
bar magnet has a net non-zero magnetic
field
but when you have a higher temperature
eventually that gets broken there's a
phase transition much like the kind of
phase transition that happens when you
boil water
for example you go it goes all from
being liquid to all to being gas at 100
degrees centigrade at standard pressure
and so on so the way that works is
that the um uh in the higgs field
will have zero if the temperature is
high enough
this uh higgs condensate will disappear
so that temperature is pretty high
temperature um
it but it's a temperature which will
have occurred in the
first microsecond i think of the
existence of the universe
um and uh so let's think it's a
microsecond
um a microsecond after the beginning of
the universe
the universe was still so hot that the
higgs field couldn't sort of line itself
up
to make the thing that would be the
higgs condensate
where the particles go through it and
they pick up their mass in the usual way
so effectively the the spontaneously
broken symmetry
that is the thing that gives mass to
particles ordinarily
doesn't isn't broken in the sufficiently
early universe
so these things effectively have zero
mass in the sufficiently early universe
um and uh so in answer to the question
can the
does the electron change its mass in
some effective sense yes
although you kind of don't notice it
that much because
when you're at that higher temperature
electrons are getting jiggled around so
much
that it's not so important what their
mass is now by the way
in our by the way this this this
uncanceled version
of the so that the higgs field then
stops existing throughout space if you
have the temperature be sufficiently
high
now this has a important consequence
because this higgs field that's supposed
to fill the whole universe
it fills the whole universe and it
produces
incredibly high energy density in the
universe
and an energy density of trillion
trillion trillion trillion trillion
times higher
than the energy that we actually see in
the universe the that term
and so again it's one of these tricks
like this renalization trick you have to
say well it's there all the time
so you don't notice it and in other
words
but um one of the questions is why does
gravity not notice it
and that is a kind of a whole giant hack
tower in the standard theory of physics
to do with this thing called the
cosmological constant
which is just this number that gets
added to the equations of gravity
um that can be used to subtract from
the what you get from this higgs column
and say it's a big hack tower
um in our theory of physics there is no
such hack tower which is very nice
um although the reason there isn't a
hack tower is even perhaps more bizarre
than everything else which is that all
of this
all of this activity that leads to higgs
condensate that leads to all these other
kinds of things i've been talking about
that activity is the same activity that
essentially knits together the structure
of space
and so this this concept that you know
all this activity is producing gravity
doesn't happen because in a sense this
activity is what makes space in the
first place
so it doesn't sort of make it doesn't it
doesn't the space already exists and
you're putting a big thing in space
that's then producing gravity it's that
this is actually making space to begin
with
so in any case that that hack tower
doesn't exist there but
in the in the standard traditional model
um
the higgs condensate is there it's it's
the incredible energy density in the
universe is cancelled by this hack
so we observe essentially zero energy
density in the current universe
but the hack is revealed as a hack a
microsecond
before a microsecond uh before the first
microsecond of the universe
because before that first microsecond
there's no longer a cancellation because
the higgs condensate
isn't there anymore it it kind of boiled
away
and so there isn't this cancellation and
so there's this giant
uncanceled piece that will do something
to the universe
what does the giant uncanceled piece do
the giant uncanceled piece
is like a whole bunch of negative mass
that exists throughout the universe well
positive mass
pulls things together according to
gravity but if you have a negative mass
the equations of gravity say
you would have gravity that repels
rather than attracts
so what that means is that when you have
this giant
uncanceled thing that behaves like
negative mass
it's as if it makes the universe all fly
apart
instead of be pulled together and so
it's an idea
actually a friend of mine and i had this
idea back in 1979
um that that when at sufficiently early
temp
early times in the universe there will
be this uncanceled higgs field
and it would lead to this uncanceled
effective negative mass cosmological
constant thing
that would cause the universe to expand
very rapidly
but we thought that wouldn't happen for
very long it wouldn't happen very much
and it wasn't something that should be
considered an important effect
later on people said but what if it did
happen
look at all the amazing things it
implies it implies a bunch of things
that explain various mysteries about the
early universe and that turned into
what's called the inflationary universe
scenario
for the early universe which has the
idea that the universe started very very
very small
and then got into this period of
exponentially rapid inflationary
expansion
and eventually it sort of cooled down to
the point where
uh more or less there was now this sort
of symmetry breaking
more or less and something like higgs
field came in
and um and and you ended up with this
cancellation and the universe sort of
calmed down
to the sort of very uh uh modest
rate of expansion only roughly the speed
of light
that it shows right now in in the
expansion of the universe
but the idea is that at earlier times
there was this exponentially rapid
expansion in the universe that sort of
inflated everything out
and you kind of know that the theory is
getting a little bit long in the you
know
a little bit in the um the ship is
sinking ones ones
turning on more and more pumps when um
there are more and more different kinds
of particles that have to be added to
make
to make it all work and there are
inflatons and inflaton fields and
it's all a bit bit of a mess which is
not a great thing because the amount
one's explaining is comparatively
limited so one
puts all these different bells and
whistles and knobs and levers and so on
into the theory
it becomes hard to actually know whether
you've got the right theory
in our models of physics um actually
things that
that happen like that are explained in a
very different way a way that may sound
more bizarre to begin with
you know in our current universe space
is more or less three-dimensional so far
as we know space is three-dimensional
but uh in our theory space
the dimensionality of space can change
in fact even in our current universe
there could be little regions
where the dimension of space is not
exactly three it might be 3.01
or 2.99 whatever else and in our theory
what seems likely to be the case is that
at at the very beginning of the universe
the universe had infinite dimensions and
only as the universe expanded
did its effective dimensionality
decrease until it eventually reaches
something like three
and in that theory one gets sort of all
the good features of this kind of
inflationary idea
without any of the hackery um and we
still have to work out actually we might
we might work on this again on
uh a live stream that we're doing next
tuesday
trying to work out how the dimension
cooldown process
happens in the early universe but that's
kind of our our version of that that
kind of theory
but so this question of do particles
always have the same mass
um the answer is in the sufficiently
early universe uh when there's this
phase transition
in the current theory they wouldn't
always have the same mass
in our theory boy it's a good question
actually
uh what would happen um
well we need a bunch of math uh we need
a bunch of math because it's really hard
to figure out
how calculus works outside of integer
dimensional space and that's what we
need for these
for these things with variable dimension
and so on and that's that's just
something that
has never been developed you know you
you learn calculus you learn calculus of
one variable
that's the first course you take then
you learn multivariate calculus calculus
of many variables you know
dealing with functions not just of x but
of x and y and z and so on
but notice that you're talking about
functions of x
x and y x and y and z there's a limited
number there's a
there's a whole number of variables you
don't say
functions of two and a half variables
you say functions of one variable
functions of two variables
what we need is calculus of functions of
any number of variables including 2.67
variables and so on
and that requires building a bunch of
new math which we've started doing
to to deal with those kinds of things
um let's see
there was a question uh
boy okay um
all right let me just try and tackle a
couple more that there was
there was another one that i thought was
going to be real difficult but maybe
it's going to be easier because
it always seems to be the case the
questions i think are easy turn out to
be difficult
and vice versa somebody asked what
is category theory category theory
is an area of pure mathematics that
makes particularly older mathematicians
a large fraction of older mathematicians
very nervous
it's a very abstract theory people who
are learning
math at a graduate school level now many
of them are learning it in terms of
category theory
but in the past that wasn't what
happened and when you
sort of have learned math the usual way
and then you're trying to reframe it
to think in terms of category theory it
feels extremely abstract
and extremely hard to understand but and
for a long time i kind of ignored
category theory as being too abstract
but it's recently become clear that our
models of physics have deep
relationships to category theory
and so i've been trying to really get my
get my brain wrapped around how category
theory works
okay what is a category a category
is made from so-called objects and
morphisms
this is going to get this is going to be
kind of abstract
so what um
the category
is um
let's see it would be
a oh boy
well here's an example category of sets
category of sets is
the collection of all possible sets of
things
so a set might be a collection a you
know an
a and a b and a c an a
um an a and a b a c and an x
these are all sets and the definition of
set says it doesn't matter what order
these things are in
it doesn't matter you don't you don't
get to say that there are two a's and
one b
it's just there's an a and there's a b
there's a certain amount of a certain
amount of b
those are sets okay so
then you say in the category of sets
you can define a mapping between sets
like you can say
one set is a subset of another set that
means
that one set uh one set contains fewer
things than the other set so one set
might contain
a and b another set might contain a b c
and d and then the a and b set as a
subset of the set a b c d
okay so that that will be a mapping from
one set to another
and the uh the sort of the the feature
of this
category thing is that there can be
these objects the sets
and there can be these morphisms these
mappings that say
like you could have a subset mapping and
you're saying
there is a uh for every for every
uh set there's this that you you can
have this
this mapping from one set to another
which is
the this uh this subset
mapping and this is not going to go well
this explanation well that
that's more or less right and there are
various other properties like you can
say that
um that if that that you can kind of go
two jumps if set x
is a subset of set y which is a subset
of set z
then set x is also a subset of set z
um there's that transitivity property
but
um and that's sort of a property so that
that that is a subset of is kind of a
morphism
in that in that uh category
um i really should be explaining this
with with a better example of objects
and and morphisms the problem is that
these things get very abstract very
quickly
because what's really going on in
category theory is you're dealing not
with very specific kinds of things like
this particular point at this particular
coordinate but you're dealing with
sort of the collection of all possible
points and mappings from one collection
of all possible points
to another collection of all possible
points and so on so it's a very abstract
kind of way of thinking about things
it's closely related if you know about
low-level programming languages
it's closely related to the theory of
types when if you say
i've got uh integer and i've got an
array of integers i've got an array of
an array of integers and things
you can you can do things that are kind
of like category theory
in terms of the types of things where
you don't say it's a particular integer
like three
you just say it's this whole sort of
category no
not not category in that sense this
whole collection of things
that are the um uh um that are all
possible integers
so what happens is the
uh you can if you want to sort of
represent these categories and with this
objects and morphisms and so on
you can you can kind of draw pictures in
which you say
there is this object and it's connected
to a more biomorphism to this object
and you can draw that as a node an arc
a node you can draw it as a graph and
so you can draw out these diagrams that
represent
categories as graphs and the the slight
trickiness because of this this property
of sort of this jump property of
morphisms
that means that the graph always has to
be filled in as a sort of transitive
closure where you're
where you're filling in every everything
where you can get from something to
something
by some route you fill in the direct
route as well
but let's ignore filling in the direct
route let's assume that we've
um we've just filled in the the one-step
routes
okay so you've got this this graph and
this graph can represent a category
okay now normally in most categories
people deal with
every node in the graph has a name it's
got it represents a particular kind of
thing it represents some
uh some collection of matrices with this
thing it represents something
it has a it has a name it has a meaning
now
in our theory of physics we have a
structure very much like this
except that the nodes which we can think
of as being nodes that are a little bit
like the nodes that exist in these
these categories don't have names at all
they're just
atoms of space and they don't have any
you just they're just as a giant bucket
of them you know if you look at a
category theory textbook you might have
diagrams with
you know 10 nodes in them or something
but now we're saying
we've got 10 to the 400 completely
anonymous nodes
and that represents something about our
universe and
the the these sort of connections
between
these atoms of space are like morphisms
more or less
and um things get more complicated
because there are
just as there are mappings from objects
to objects through morphisms there are
mappings from morphisms to morphisms
through things called funk doors and um
you can build up these kind of higher
categories
by looking at things which are mappings
between mappings between whatever
i told you this is quite abstract um but
in our um in our kind of theory of
physics
these higher categories have meanings
that correspond to certain things about
the way the the way that uh that things
cause other things in the universe the
kind of the graph that represents the
graph of causal relationships
is a higher order category type graph
and in our theories of physics actually
the most bizarre thing is the infinity
category
where you've gone and said i'm going to
look at
the mappings between mappings between
mappings between mappings and infinite
number of times
that object the so-called infinity
category or
actually so-called infinity groupoid
because it inevitably has certain extra
properties
that thing is an incredibly bizarre
abstract sort of
that's kind of at the outer limits of
abstraction
for um for lots of mathematics that gets
done it was invented in the 1960s by
a guy called alexander grothendik who
was one of the
more abstract mathematicians of of any
time i think
um but anyway so so this
infiniti groupoid thing is this kind of
limit
of taking sort of mappings of mappings
of magnetic mappings on categories
and the um uh in our model of physics
it turns out that infinity groupoid has
a has an interpretation
and it is essentially the the thing that
represents
all possible histories of all possible
rules
for the evolution of the universe so
in in a particular universe with a
particular rule for how it evolves
there are these different possible
histories from different places you can
apply the rule
those different possible histories give
you quantum mechanics there is
another thing one can look at which is
to look at not
just all possible applications of a
single rule but to say
we don't know what the rule for the
universe is why doesn't it follow all
possible rules
it turns out that our universe can be
thought of as following all possible
rules
and we're merely in our particular
experience of the universe we're merely
sampling
a slice of that sort of universal
possible universes of all possible rules
but this thing i told you this was
abstract
this thing this infinity groupoid thing
is the thing that represents
the the collection of all possible
histories
for all possible universes following all
possible rules
that is the infinity group void and then
there's a conjecture that growth indeed
made
that it is inevitable that the infinity
groupoid behaves as if it has certain
kinds of spatial properties
it behaves as if it is even though it's
made in this way of saying its mappings
and mappings and mappings mapping
mappings
it will behave as if it's like something
where you could think of it
as um as a piece of um as a sort of a
piece of space where you mark out pieces
of space and you just
you just sort of say i've got this piece
of paper for example i'm going to mark
it out like graph paper
and that will be my approximation to
this the the sort of continuous space
that represents the piece of paper
the claim is that it's inevitable that
in the infinity groupoid
there is some kind of spatial limit of
that type
and probably that inevitability is what
trickles down
eventually to be the thing that
represents space
in our in our physical universe but
that's um so
so in a sense this is the i mean that
that's the
sort of the upper reaches of the
infinite limit of of category theory
which itself
is an upper uh sort of abstraction of
the way that mathematics works
and the whole thing is is sort of a
giant tower of abstraction
um but it is interesting that um
um the limit of that giant tower
abstraction seems to actually
have quite a lot to do with our our
actual universe um i think that the um
uh one of the things that is true about
category theory
is that mathematics has this has a
tremendous habit of just saying
you know things work like this you can
map this to this
you say well how would i actually do
that can i program a computer to do that
well that's where things get more
complicated because math just says
there's a function f you apply f to x
you get a result
it doesn't say how difficult is it to
apply that that f to x
and when you're trying to relate this to
physics it can matter
kind of how difficult is it to do this
and that leads to a kind of concept of
of
computationally bounded category theory
which is the thing that we're
sort of starting to work out how that
works and it will tell one a bunch of
things
that are even closer kind of
correspondence between actually between
category theory
and the theory of computation um as well
as to physics
all right that was that was uh that was
scarily difficult here
um the uh
let's see maybe one more let me pick one
that i think is going to be easy
um
this you ask very interesting questions
guys
okay uh question from frost
i'm going to pick a very different kind
of question here is it possible to make
a lens or camera for wi-fi
what would differ from a regular cmos
digital camera can there be a pinhole
wi-fi camera that's an interesting
question
so what is wi-fi wi-fi is radio waves
uh what are radio waves well they're
electromagnetic radiation
just like light except at a much lower
frequency than light
whereas light consists of
electromagnetic waves
that are uh varying
uh like a trillion times a second
they're wiggling up and down
and the wavelength is uh on the order of
um
uh 0.6 like like on the order of a half
half a millionth of a meter so
um the uh right 500 nanometers yeah
that's um yes that's right so uh
so like the wavelength of light the sort
of wiggling distance
for light is is very short it's a it's a
tiny fraction of a millimeter a tiny
fraction of a micron
uh for the radio waves
that are relevant for wi-fi
um the wavelength is much longer so the
wavelength
is of the order of
centimeters i think let's see i can work
it out
at 2 gigahertz the typical frequency is
2 gigahertz or 5 gigahertz
those are typical frequencies that
things like wi-fi operate on
so what does 5 gigahertz mean it means
um
5 billion uh oscillations per second
so that's the frequency is five billion
uh oscillations per second and uh
then what you have to do to work out the
wavelength is you have this wave that's
wiggling up and down
uh that many times per second and the
wave is traveling at the speed of light
and so what you have to do is work out
um uh
the the speed of light divided by that
so let's just do that the speed of light
is 3 times 10 to the eight three hundred
million
meters per second um convenient fact is
light goes one foot in a nanometer in a
nanosecond
so let's see if if light goes one foot
in a nanosecond
what five gigahertz means is
so that's five billion uh
uh oscillations per second
and um um a nano
meter is a billionth of a meter
so what that's telling us is that at
five gigahertz
that is um uh
one-fifth of um uh that that means that
the
um it's one five billionth
of um uh of a second is the
is the time associated with that so in
one five billionth of it
one one one-fifth of a billionth of a
second that's one-fifth of a nanosecond
that means that light will have gone
because i mentioned that light goes a
foot in a nanosecond
that means light has gone one-fifth of a
foot or a couple of inches
so that means that the wavelength of
wi-fi is
kind of what i said a few inches few
centimeters whatever that's the
that's the order of magnitude whereas
the wavelength of light is is very tiny
compared to that
so the question is if you want to have
a sort of wi-fi camera how would you do
that
well okay for for a an ordinary camera
what you're interested in doing is
taking
uh taking light that comes into the
camera and the light may be coming from
a long way away it's all in parallel
it's all coming in in parallel rays and
you want to concentrate
all that light so it comes to a focus at
a point you do that with the lens
in the case of um and and the
the when you detect the light you're
detecting it by detecting its effect
on a piece of electronics like a ccd a
charge coupled device or something like
that
that um where the the photon from the
from the light is essentially uh
changing the characteristics of an
electron in the material which you can
pick up electrically and so that's how
you detect
the presence of the photon it's how it's
how it works in a digital camera it's
how how it works in our eyes
it's basically converting the photon to
an
electrical signal and that's the result
okay
well so you don't need to do the same
kind of thing
when you're dealing with so so by the
way the wavelength of light
is comparable to the size of an atom so
you don't get to have things which vary
over the size of
of uh you can't make something where you
have where you have sort of the
where the detector is varying over
distances comparable to the wavelength
of the
of the of the wave but in the case of
wi-fi you've got a wavelength that is a
few inches
and so you can have a completely
different way of detecting the presence
of the wi-fi
and the way you do it is using an
antenna um and in an antenna
you're using the fact that the that
one hot one side of the antenna will
experience a different part of the wave
than the other side of the antenna
for light to make an antenna for light
you would have to have something
which has a size comparable to the size
of an atom
you'd have to be able to sort of measure
the difference of what the light did on
one side of the atom as compared to
another side of the atom
in some sense some kinds of ways of
detecting light do do that but
you can't expect to build an actual
detector
where you are um effectively sort of
setting it up
kind of electrically on a large scale to
kind of detect one side of the wave
versus the other side of the wave but
for
radio waves you can and that's how
antennas more or less work
and so what what you do when you detect
wi-fi
is you use an antenna and actually you
can do even more than that
you can use if you really want to get
fancy you can use
the phased array antenna in which you're
very carefully measuring
exactly when did that when did that
radio wave arrive
at that part of the antenna so let's say
we have an antenna and it's spread out
and we've got a a radio wave that's
coming from
the left at a certain angle so what will
happen is
the radio wave will hit a particular
particular moment of the wave
radio waves oscillations will hit the
left-hand side of the antenna
before it hits the right-hand side of
the antenna and so
by being kind of clever you can you can
kind of detect
the fact that it hit one side of the
antenna before it hit the other side of
the antenna
and that's that's done at so-called
phased array
it's sensitive to the phase of the wave
that uh
which is being detected and so you can
do that very directly for
radio waves in fact you can do it so
well these days that you can even do it
in software
you can basically have uh essentially
just pieces of wire hanging out of your
computer
and you can uh with the computer just
in software you can work out oh there's
this amount of electromagnetic energy
on this wire at this time and this
amount at this time you can kind of
unravel that
to say there's this radio wave coming
from this direction
and so in the case of radio waves you
don't really need
a um you don't need things like lenses
because you can directly pick up
kind of this this um uh this this
question of where
where things coming from now in a sense
you do sometimes use things like lenses
when you have a
a radio telescope or a parabolic dish
what's happening is
lots of radio waves are coming in and
just like
in a reflecting telescope you're
reflecting off the dish
can just be a metal dish or even a mesh
for for those wavelengths
and you're you're the the the dish is in
this parabolic shape
that is such that wherever the radio
hits
the radio wave hits on the parabolic
dish it will always end up being
reflected
into that same focal point in the middle
of the thing so that's kind of the
analog i suppose of a
that is kind of the analog of a lens for
um
uh for wi-fi will be a parabolic dish
that collects
the um the wi-fi and concentrates at a
particular focus but
typically you don't need that for
ordinary wi-fi because you can just
do that with an antenna now you might
ask the question
is there a way to make something like a
lens where you have
you have the radio waves and you're
bending the radio waves
to um uh um uh just like a
glass spends the the light and the
answer is yes you can do that there are
materials
that will do that um there are
various kinds of
i think um
thinking for some reason that paraffin
wax does that but i can't remember
exactly why that that it behaves like
a thing with a refractive index for
radio waves but but there are materials
that do that i mean they're
they're basically just like with light
there are some materials that are just
opaque light just doesn't go through and
there are some materials that are
transparent
light goes through but it goes through
at a different speed with it with a
certain refractive index
and the fact that it's going through the
material but at a different speed
will cause you to be able to make a lens
by by shaping the thing in the right way
that will take rays of light that are
off axis
and make them go closer to the axis so
the answer is you could make such a lens
with materials that are in a sense
transparent
to uh to wi-fi um and uh and then
concentrate things that way and i i
think it's probably the case that when
you
when you detect like you figure out what
objects are in a room
by working out uh the effect on the
wi-fi signal
i think what's happening there i think
many objects are sufficiently
transparent to wi-fi
that you are seeing this kind of effect
you're seeing kind of the the
concentration of these waves
of of these radio waves that you're then
detecting but typically you're detecting
things
um with uh uh
with antennas rather than with them uh
with kind of lenses
and and it's not even clear um if you
concentrated all the radio energy from
one point
um it is not uh because of the way
quantum mechanics works
um you won't be able to build something
like one of these charge-coupled devices
where photon arrives uh electron is
promoted and is
in in the in the material and can
produce a kind of electric effect
um that's it's related to but not quite
the same as i think of the photoelectric
effect
and basically what happens there is in
order to
get that effect to happen you need
photons where the individual photon is
of a certain energy
and the individual photons energy
depends on the frequency of the
electromagnetic radiation
higher frequencies or higher energies
and when you have
the the frequency of of a photon in
that existing radio wave is way too low
to to produce the effect that you need
to get
the kind of light to electricity
conversion
that happens in um uh in something like
a digital camera
but it isn't too low to be able to
detect the presence of the
of the of the radio wave by its effect
on individual electrons moving back and
forth inside of wire
and that's what an antenna is doing and
that's how that's how one detects these
things in an antenna
so it's different so different things at
different frequencies i mean if you go
to
way different frequencies like x-rays
which are even much much higher
frequencies of electromagnetic reaction
than ordinary light
then there are yet different detection
mechanisms although
once again because it's higher frequency
not lower frequency
this you can kick the electron
in a material to turn photons
of electromagnetic radiation into
electricity that works
for x-rays and that's why in modern
times
uh you know if you get a an x-ray done
it'll be done digitally there'll be a
digital uh
camera that is uh that's that's
producing the x-ray image
and that works using the same basic
technology that a standard digital
camera for ordinary light works
um in the past uh well actually in the
past the way that x-ray film worked was
actually
surprisingly similar to the way that
film for ordinary light worked as well
but none of that stuff will work for
radio because
just the way quantum mechanics is set up
it just doesn't have the individual
photons
that you could associate with the radio
waves just don't have enough energy
to kick the electron enough that it can
produce an electrical effect
all right i think we should probably um
uh
wrap up there i'm um i'm noticing one
one question for you from aoix asking
what would happen if you live streamed a
video from a vessel that is going near
the speed of light
would it be slowed down answer yes
i mean in other words the perceived time
for me i'd be yakking and talking at my
full speed
and uh and you guys if you were to
receive that
that video um you know i transmit the
video
that video would be uh
the you know my um
uh what for me would be full speed
for you would be slow slow slow and and
roughly what's happening
um in our theory of physics we kind of
understand from a fundamental point of
view what's happening there
when you get to kind of
sample the evolution of the universe
you can either sort of
use the use the sort of little bits of
computation that get done
to kind of progress in time
and have all that gesticulation and
yakking go on
or you can use that computational
process to move in space
and so what's essentially happening is
that
the uh that that
spacecraft traveling is using its sort
of computational effort
to both move in space and make time
progress for things inside it
and the time for the for the folks
inside the spacecraft
they're like well things are happening
just as things happen you can't tell
that
because everything inside the spacecraft
is happening on that time scale it just
seems like normal time to you
so you're just going to be yakking at
your normal speed in that time
but because the spacecraft is kind of
using some of its computation
to progress to move in space as well as
using
using its computation to progress in
time it
its notion of progressing in time is
slower
than the notion of progressing in time
for somebody who is
at rest so to speak rather than
traveling at the speed of spacecraft
so that's kind of the that's kind of the
um uh the sort of operational version of
why relativity works
uh by the way that's you won't find that
in any textbooks yet
maybe you will after the last six months
but but probably you won't find that yet
um you will eventually find that um but
the
the basic idea is it's kind of the
universe is doing computation
and uh sort of the the computation can
either be used to progress in time or
can be used to move in space
and for the folks inside the spacecraft
they don't know
that some of their computation is being
used to move in space they just say
things are happening at the rate things
are happening um but
when you compare that to what's
happening outside the spacecraft it's
slower
so what will be happening is uh that
when
when the um uh
the video stream would start up and it
would be
uh the the uh it would just
it would um uh you know that you would
you would be perceiving
a um a a slower video
than uh than i would be sort of
experiencing so to speak
um and uh yeah
oh there was another question here i
can't resist doing this one as well just
for a second and then i really should go
um there's a question here from woolsock
what's up with the muons discovered
okay that's kind of relates to some sort
of favorite questions of mine so
okay i'll just do this one
so there are electrons and uh
they're also strangely in the 1930s
there were particles discovered called
muons
which are so far as we can tell just
like electrons
but 206 times heavier roughly it's not
exactly 206
and muons because they're heavier than
electrons they can actually decay into
electrons and
neutrinos and things they love about two
and a half 2.2 microseconds
um in cosmic rays uh protons streaming
out from the sun
when they hit the earth's atmosphere a
lot of them are converted into
whole showers or particles and on the
surface of the earth at sea level
there is a flux of muons and you can
detect those
um they come through about in a
person-sized object
there's a muon going through you about
once a minute
um and so once a minute muon streaks
through you doesn't really do anything
to you
um uh the um
uh but muons are these things that are
like electrons but 206 times heavier
and so far as we've been able to tell
every property of muons is just like the
properties of electrons but with the
mass
being 206 times heavier okay so one of
the very subtle things
that people have been interested in is a
thing called the anomalous magnetic
moment of the electron the anomalous
magnetic moment of the muon
so if you put a muon okay electrons and
muons
both have this property called spin
which is essentially
angular momentum associated with the
particle and one thing that happens is
if you put they're like little bar
magnets
and um they if you if you put them in a
magnetic field
they will those bar magnets
the sort of relationship between the
spinning and the bar magnets
causes the sort of the spinning thing to
process
slightly and the most obvious rate of
procession would be
there's a quantity called g the
gyromagnetic ratio
will be g equals two and if g equals two
uh certain things keep lined up and and
and feet in
in uh the the the spin of an electron
will get
keep lined up as it rotates around in in
magnetic fields and so on but any case
there is an anomalous magnetic moment of
the electron
and the muon where g differs from two so
called g minus two
um and that quantity is something that
is the pride and joy
of quantum electrodynamics is the
computation of that quantity
and because it turns out it can be
computed it's really hard to compute
and people get um it is i think
what is it 10 decimal digits by now of
precise agreement between
incredibly complicated calculations and
the theoretical predictions
and the theoretical predictions the
reason there are calculations i was
talking about virtual particles earlier
the um uh the the whole um
uh anonymous magnetic moment calculation
is a sort of festival of virtual
particles
there are virtual photons there are
virtual electron positive pairs there
are virtual
everything in the end and so the
calculation of g minus two
depends on the contributions of all
these kinds of virtual particles
a very elaborate calculation takes years
of computer time
but you can get an actual answer okay so
people got actual answers
and they did actual measurements and
it's very hard by the time
the first few approximations you know
the first term
is um in some notation it's you know
1 plus alpha over 2 pi that's pretty
simple
plus some much more complicated thing
with pi cubes and
and zeta functions and all kinds of
things that's a next order term
and so on and so on and so on these
successive terms get progressively
smaller
but if you're trying to get it to
sufficient accuracy you have to keep
uh basically uh well so-called eighth
order or tenth order
which is actually half that number of
terms so five five of those kinds of
terms
um but uh okay so people have done these
very elaborate calculations that are
very difficult to do
get a definite answer then people go out
and measure
the g minus two values for electrons and
muons
and there was just a new measurement
done of the g minus two for the muon
and it disagrees with the theoretical
calculation
now you know as a kind of a long-time
observer of the world of physics
both the theory and the experiment are
really hard
so whether there is a significant
difference or whether there's just some
small mistake that's been made somewhere
i think it's way too early to tell but
it is
it is uh it would be interesting if
there was a difference between the
theory and the experiment um
it might even be something that will be
approved for some of the things in our
theory
i was planning to work that out i
haven't worked it out yet um
it may be a reflection of something to
do with qcd the theory of quarks and
gluons
which you might say what does that have
to do with electrons by the time you've
got all these virtual particles you've
got virtual everything's
including virtual quarks virtual gluons
you know virtual w
bosons virtual everything and so the
whole spectrum of particles kind of a
weird situation
the whole even within when you think
you're looking at an electron because of
this virtual particle effect because of
this sort of
uh these fluctuations of the vacuum that
cause all these virtual particle pairs
to be produced for all kinds of
particles
you've effectively got a reflection of
all possible particles that can
that can occur um so
anyway that was that was that story all
right well thank you for
for lots of great questions here and um
uh it will be useful actually to get
some feedback on whether these
explanations are are just
way too technical or um
or whether people want to know i mean i
i try to let you know
some of the buzz terms that you can go
look up and things
for some of the things that i'm talking
about but there's there's
at every at every stage there are kind
of buzz terms for what's going on
that you can go and search for on the
web and things like that
um and uh i could tell you some more of
those they just
that you know from a sort of everyday
point of view they just sound really
exotic
um and uh
but um uh perhaps fun okay
well thanks all very much and um
i'll uh um be back again
i hope to be able to do this next week
i'm not completely sure
might have to skip next week we'll have
to see um
uh the um but next wednesday i just want
to advertise
it is the first anniversary of the
launch
of our world from physics project and
i'll be doing a live stream talking
about what we've learned in the past
year
and kind of what we can see going
forward there's a lot of exciting stuff
that we've learned
and there's a lot of really exciting
stuff to come and uh it's really
it's not a thing i ever expected to see
but we're really
successfully decoding how this universe
of ours works
and um it's pretty neat and i think
i'm beginning to i don't think i
necessarily quite yet
i'm beginning to kind of as i look at
physical objects
sort of start thinking really underneath
this is this whole
weird thing and so on i don't think i
think that might drive a little bit
crazy to think that way but
and i kind of imagine it for a moment
and then it's back to yeah it's a
physical
piece of chocolate or something and
don't worry about it
okay anyway um all right that's it for
for here for now um bye for now see you
another